Sie persönlich Sorge dass
Wladimir Putin an Atombombe einsetzen
könnte in den nächsten Monaten in den
nächsten Jahren in diesem Krieg ich
glaube dass wir in der Situation sind
das hat ja auch ja mehrfaches Nachfragen
zu meiner Begriffswahl wo ich gesagt
habe ich formuliere das mal bewusst
überspitzt das schlägt sofort ein als
wenn man Dinge absolut stellt deswegen
halte ich überhaupt nichts davon zu
spekulieren zu spekulieren gerade im
Bereichen die natürlich für viele
Menschen besorgniserregen sind wir
überprüfen ständig mit unseren eigenen
Sicherheitsdiensten mit den
Sicherheitsdienst und
Nachrichtendiensten von unserem
befreundeten Partnern die die Situation
ist wir haben deutlich gemacht
ich habe nicht die Sorge dass ein Mittel
gewählt wird was dazu führen würde dass
mit Blick auf die globale Situation
die Welt komplett eine andere wäre weil
es ist ja so dass der russische
Präsident das sieht man ja auch an
seinen Äußerungen schon sehr genau
beobachtet wie ist die globale Resonanz
deswegen mehr als Außenminister auch so
wichtig ist weltweit zu erklären was wir
hier tun als der Vorwurf war wir würden
verhindern dass Getreide aus Russland
rauskommt war ich überall unterwegs und
habe gesagt das stimmt nicht es gibt
keine Sanktionen auf Lebensmittel und so
ist es auch hier in diesem Bereich es
ist vollkommen klar für den russischen
Präsidenten das im Nuklearbereich wo
Nuklearwaffen geächtet sind es gibt nur
leerstaaten die sie natürlich haben aber
vollkommen klar ist dass dass die Welt
so ein Schritt nicht akzeptieren würde
dass auch ein russischer Präsident genau
weiß dass solche Sachen solche Waffen
nicht zum Einsatz kommen mit einer
schnellen Antwort
viele Menschen fragen sich wann ist
dieser Krieg zu Ende und wie kann das
Leiden gestoppt werden wie lange wird
dieser Krieg dauern ich wünschte ich
wüsste es weil dann hätte ich auch den
Schlüssel in Hand diesen Krieg zu
beenden und wenn ich
diese Kräfte hätte dann wäre der Krieg
gestern vorbei gewesen aber die brutale
Realität ist dass diesen Schlüssel
derzeit der russische Präsident allein
in der Hand hält wenn der Krieg vorbei
sein sollte das Leiden das Bomben dann
könnte Putin diesen Krieg morgen stoppen
er will es nicht und deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass wir die Ukraine weiterhin
auch wenn Sie Fragen stellen warum geht
es nicht schneller weiterhin
unterstützen dass sie sich verteidigen
können jahrelanger Krieg
das weiß ich nicht wir tun alles dafür
dass der Krieg zu Ende geht deswegen
telefoniert der Kanzler deswegen ist der
Generalsekretär unterwegs deswegen sind
wir immer wieder dabei mit den Indern zu
sprechen mit den Chinesen zu sprechen
mit denjenigen zu sprechen die von sich
behaupten ihre
sogenannte Neutralität würde dazu
beitragen dass der Krieg zu Ende geht
aber das ist eben das weswegen ist auch
so wichtig ist dass viel wie sie
begonnen haben wir nicht schweigen
weil wenn wir dieses Verhalten
akzeptieren würden wir andere Länder
einladen das gleiche zu tun und das
können wir nicht verantworten und da wo
wir Verantwortung jetzt derzeit in
burreale Politik übertragen können tun
wir das das sind die Waffenlieferungen
das sind auch humanitäre Lieferungen das
ist die Aufnahme von geflüchteten das
ist die Versorgung mit Getreide in der
Welt und die Geschlossenheit die wir
haben wenn ich diese Minute noch habe
möchte ich das einmal sagen ich erlebe
ein Land ich erlebe eine Europäische
Union wo viele gefragt haben wozu
brauchen wir Europa was soll das bitte
sein dass Friedensprojekt Europa jetzt
spüren wir alle dass der größte Segen
auch für uns ist in einer gemeinsamen
europäischen Union zu leben und diese
beieinander zu halten dass sich auch als
die Zentrale aus Aufnahme
müssen beendet werden also wo ist da die
Gemeinsamkeiten
der letzte ist Ende des Satzes was ich
gerade gesagt habe deswegen ist auch
eine zentrale Aufgabe einer deutschen
Außenministerin in dieser Situation
schon alles dafür zu tun dass die
europäische Geschlossenheit beieinander
bleibt und wir eben deutlich machen auch
gegen unseren ungarischen
Nachbarn dass wir in dieser Situation
beieinander stehen müssen solidarisch
bei der Energieversorgung europaweit und
auch bei dem durchhalten von Sanktionen
und das weiß auch Ungarn das weiß der
westliche Balkan wenn wir da jetzt
irgendwie bröcke in unserer Solidarität
was müssen wir was muss Moldau denken
was müssen all die anderen Länder denken
die auch Sorge haben dass Russland sie
angreifen könnte für diesen Worten
herzlichen Dank Frau bärbock und
wir hoffen dass dieser Krieg schneller
zu Ende geht als wir alle denken